- So now that you've
officially met everyone.
- Oh yes, yes, yes.
- [Kelly] Yes, yes.
I have to lead with this.
- Yes.
- She was one of my
favorite singers, okay?
So I have to lead with it.
- [DeVaughn] I know where we're going.
- I can't even believe you're
the son in "The Bodyguard."
It's crazy to me.
In the movie I was like...
(audience applauding)
I did not...
I've seen you and stuff
and I think 'cause you were so little
I didn't translate...
It did not translate to me.
And I just thought "Was that...
I know you're probably tired of this but-
- [DeVaughn] No.
- I have to ask 'cause she's Whitney.
(DeVaughn laughing)
What was that like?
Do you remember?
'Cause you were so little.
- Yes I was so little.
It was mind blowing.
But one of the things I
remember, I was eight.
So I didn't even care
about Whitney Houston
at that time, right?
- [Kelly] That's what I'm saying-
- Right.
Right.
- [Kelly] That's why I
think it's so funny. Yeah.
- That was the first
time I actually saw snow.
So I was just like, "Oh
cool, this is great."
And you know-
- Whitney Houston's there like, "Snow!"
- [DeVaughn] Yeah, yeah.
Whitney Houston, Kevin Costner.
- You're like Olaf. (laughs)
- Yeah.
- I think it's amazing
- Regardless.
And I remember she took me
into her trailer one time
and she was singing.
And I was like, "Oh
dang girl, you can sing?
(audience laughing)
- Oh my God I love that.
- So now I'm yeah...
I feel silly saying that.
- No, she probably loved that.
- [DeVaughn] Yeah. I think
it's so innocent and pure.
And it was just such a huge...
I mean speaking of huge pop culture things
with "Friends" and "The Bodyguard"-
- Yeah.
- Leads to these huge moments.
And I didn't know you were the
same kid. I didn't know that.
And I'd seen you and so then
I was like, "Wait, what?"
- Yeah. (chuckles)
- [Kelly] Anyway, so I had to ask.
You're welcome.
But your stepmom is
Debbie Allen whom I love,
and your father is former
NBA player, Norm Nixon.
- Yep.
- So you went into the
entertainment industry
instead of basketball.
That was just the field you wanted?
- Yeah, that was the field I wanted.
And my stepmother was
always like, "Dance,"
and my dad was like, "Basketball."
She was like, "Dance" and "Basketball,"
you know what I mean?
(audience laughing)
But it was really my biological-
- You could have been like
the Harlem Globetrotter.
It's like a both.
I feel like they do both. (chuckles)
- Yeah, so my biological mother
and my grandfather used to
drop me off at the theater.
Well not by myself, but
I went with my grandpa,
and we used to theater hop,
which we can't do anymore.
People are standing at the door like,
"Hey man, you got your ticket.
- [Kelly] Yep.
- But I remember just her dropping us off
at seven in the morning and
picking us up around like five,
and I would see all of the movies.
- [Lisa] Wow!
- Yeah.
- And so that's kind of how
I got into the industry,
and I started as OshKosh
B'gosh model so...
- Oh my God, I remember.
(audience applauding)
- Yeah, yeah.
- You're like bodyguard, Schmodiguard
- Yeah, bodyguard, Schmodiguard, whatever.
- (laughing) Love it.
So speaking of your father,
so you play him in this series, right?
- Yep.
- One, do you audition for
that or do you just get that?
'Cause why would they make
you audition I feel like...
- I know, I know.
But I actually wanted to
go through the process.
- (gasps) So you did? (gasps)
- [DeVaughn] Yeah.
My buddy texted me. He was like,
"You should play your dad."
And I pre-read and got a call back
and finally I got it so...
- That's amazing.
(audience applauding)
Well that's kinda cool,
'cause then you had to
go through the process.
But I mean, was that
weird for you to be like,
"Hey dad, I'm playing you."
- Oh my dad, he's very non script, chill.
And I remember telling him,
"Yo dad, I'm playing you."
And he was like, "Cool."
(audience laughing)
- Nixon, I bet he wasn't like,
"Don't make me look bad."
- Yeah, yeah.
No, no, that actually
is one thing he said.
No, straight up, straight up.
He was like, "You not walking around
playing a fictitious character,
so don't make me look stupid."
- Oh my God, I love it. (laughs)
I love that, I love it.
Tell us about the show.
- So the show-
- You look kind of hardcore in the clip.
- Yeah, yeah.
The show, the most challenging
part about it for me
was my dad was very lean.
He was skinnier.
I was pushing 185, 190,
the physical aspect of it.
So I went through
intermittent fasting, HBO-
(Kelly gasps)
Yeah, they gave us meal plans
and we had a rigorous workout routine.
- That's where I'm like, "Out."
- We had practice.
Yeah, right. (laughs)
You're like, "See ya."
- I'm sorry, "What?"
- So I mean yeah, that was
the toughest part for me.
'cause I'm thinking about pizza right now,
you know what I mean?
- Yeah. (laughs)
- [Lisa] (laughing) Oh my God. (laughing)
- That's hard, to get you through...
But I bet you felt really prepared though
once you were doing it.
- Absolutely.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And it was great.
I felt like I was in the
best shape of my life,
and I just felt good about
stepping into his shoes,
'cause I just wanted to do him justice.
- Has he seen it?
- I mean, he's seen it enough
to tell me that he didn't wear a fur coat.
(audience laughs)
- [Kelly] Wait, what?
He told you he didn't...
Oh and you're wearing a fur coat-
- [DeVaughn] Yeah, yeah.
He was like, "Man..."
He was like "I'm from making Georgia,
how am I gon' play
basketball in a fur coat?"
(audience laughing)
- You just decided to
put him in a fur coat,
this is awesome.
- I mean no.
That was, that was their
decision so... (laughs)
- He never wore a fur coat before?
- See that's the thing.
So our costume designer,
Emma Potter she was like,
"Your dad says he never
wore a fur a coat?"
She was like, "What's this?"
I was like, "See?" (laughs)
- She was like, "Skrr!" (laughs)
I love that.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I love that!
- Yeah, oh here it is! Old
man is in a fur, you see It?
- [Kelly] Lies and deception.
- [DeVaughn] Yeah, lies and deception.
- [Kelly] What happened
when you showed him that?
- [DeVaughn] (gasps) He was like-
- [Kelly] I would've enjoyed that moment.
- "Well, little bit of fur
around the collar man."
(Kelly laughing)